and we begin today with our coronavirus
coverage the nevada national guard is
playing a critical role in the fight
against coven 19. they have been for
months
well this week governor steve sisolak
announced troops will remain in place
and continue to provide support at test
sites all across the state
and that includes texas station that's a
busy site hector mejia is there live for
us with the details hi hector
hey there there's been a steady stream
of cars here showing up for testing
right now it looks like
there's a pretty short line right now
there we see one car going by and the
testing is happening inside the parking
garage
inside you'll find soldiers and airmen
helping run the operations
these are men and women who have fought
for us abroad since april we've seen
hundreds of nevada national guardsmen on
the front lines
at mobile test sites across the valley
they'll stay on duty at least through
the end of march of 2021
major general andre berry believes that
extension will likely last longer
possibly into the summer according to
the state's website the positivity rate
went up again this week it's now
18.4 percent statewide berry says
they're preparing in the event governor
steve sislak asks the guard
to help with the vaccine distribution
and this morning barry came to texas
station to thank the soldiers in person
for their efforts and also for providing
hope to nevadans
if you told me that the guard would be
handling food distribution
or if you would have told me the guard
would be handling
ppe if you told me the guard will be
testing
or doing contact tracing i just would
never believe that
and so i think we'll look back and say
this has been a defining moment
for the national guard in terms of
what's going on in the country
when people see this when they show up
when they drive up
or see food being handed out it's a
symbol of hope
this has been the largest and longest
activation in the state's history
in terms of funding the federal
government is paying 75 percent
while the state pays the rest the guard
has assisted in a number of emergency
events most recently they helped put out
wildfires
and with the civil unrest we saw in las
vegas over the summer
and troops are also traveling across the
state providing testing
this site is open thursdays through
mondays between 8 a.m
and 4 p.m on a first come first served
basis
reporting near texas station hector
mejia 8 news now